[Music]
now look towards each other
how bad are you gonna beat him it's me
there's a lot at stake here reputations
are at stake bro there is chad's
reputation my reputation's on the line i
believe in 85 here
[Music]
here we go
who is this freeze
this is it
[Music]
let's go 85.
false start on the freeze
open up
[Music]
photo finish we ain't gonna listen to a
cabbie sham hey we gotta go back to the
replay
come here big boy
freeze got you by a kneecap
i should have though
[Music]
recap of the race
first of all end result i won
that's all that matters i opened up
oh
oh
hey
i'm freezing you get that i'm freezing
hey joe yeah welcome to the show i'm the
main attraction
what's this um he's already complaining
[Applause]
what are we doing this is a catastrophe
but now they know what it feels like and
people tried to cover me on sundays
i know you made 15. it's decent not that
good but let's see if i can do a little
bit more
we'll roll that back in editing it'll be
16 but bryce
[Music]
you